what I'm going to tell you is obviously
too little too late and it's also what
we all knew but we now have actually
heard from FBI director Christopher Rea
that yeah
the investigation so called
investigation into allegations against
now Supreme Court justice for life Brett
Kavanaugh of sexual assault that
investigation was indeed significantly
limited in scope and restricted by
design by virtue of the type of
investigation it was so this we're gonna
play some video clips in a second but
this is really important to understand
the debate or the argument when the
so-called investigation was going on was
about whether the investigation had or
hadn't been restricted as a matter of an
individual investigations sort of course
what Christopher Rea testified yesterday
before the Senate when questioned by
Senator Kamala Harris
was that all of these types of
investigations happen within the
boundaries established by the White
House like there was never we were
having a debate over did Trump say X Y
or Z or was this an open investigation
but the truth is what Christopher Rea
explains is all of these investigations
are specifically limited to what the
White House wants Trump insisted you
might recall that there were no limits
that the FBI can do whatever it wants he
tweeted and we showed you this tweet
back when it happened and I'll show it
to you again Trump tweeted NBC News
incorrectly reported as usual that I was
limiting the FBI investigation of Judge
Cavanaugh and witnesses only to certain
people actually I want them to interview
whoever they deem appropriate at their
discretion please correct your reporting
this was absolutely ridiculous when he
said it we also know now that it of
course was a lie they they in the course
of that investigation the FBI didn't
even speak to Brett Kavanaugh himself
dr. Christine Blasi Ford herself any
investigation that doesn't speak to the
principal's is clearly not a full
investigation let alone the dozens of
people who knew Brett Kavanaugh and
Christine four at the time who wanted to
speak the FBI
at him so here is the first part of
Christopher Rea telling Kamala Harris
about the investigation take a listen
was the FBI given full discretion or was
the scope of the investigation limited
by the direction you received from the
White House well senator I want to be a
little bit careful what I can can talk
about in this setting there I'm not
asking you for the content of the
investigators doing understood there are
MO use and other things that go back
aways the governor's but I think it's
important I would say this it's
important to understand that the unlike
most investigations like the sort that
you and I and Senator Jones have all
been familiar with traditional Criminal
Investigations National Security
Investigations a background
investigation is very different and that
is done our only Authority is as
requested by the adjudicating you know
my house in this case is the white house
right he's saying here that by
definition this type of investigation is
directed and limited and and sort of put
in place by the White House the FBI does
what the white house requests and
doesn't go beyond that so he's framing
it as this is a feature of these types
of investigations not a bug but that's
what it is and then continuing with this
questioning take a look and I have a lot
to cover and so if we can be as succinct
as possible I appreciate it and I know
there were there a lot of details and I
appreciate your point so in this
situation was your direction
limited in scope or were you given full
direct discretion to investigate
whatever your agency thought was
appropriate to figure out what happened
I think I would say that our
investigation here are supplemental
update to the previous background
investigation was limited in scope and
then that is consistent with the
standard process for such investigations
going back quite a long ways it was
limited in scope just like all of these
types of investigations are by
definition so in fact not only was the
Cavanaugh investigation limited in
in this specific case these types of
investigations are at their core
directed by the white house in terms of
scope limits and borders so did Trump
lie when he said there were no limits
probably unfortunately there's not going
to be any repercussion for that I mean
the I read online people saying are we
now going to investigate Trump for lying
about this of course not of course not
will there be any repercussions for
Brett Kavanaugh no the entire thing was
a joke from the get-go and now I'm
curious about Jeff Lakes role in this
did Jeff Flake deliberately request this
investigate investigation as part of a
plan knowing that it would be a limited
investigation or did he end up sort of
being a useful idiot or a stooge whether
where he might have been acting in good
faith when he said we need we've got to
delay these confirmation hearings
because we need an investigation into
Brett Kavanaugh and and it ended up that
he was taken advantage of by Mitch
McConnell chuck Grassley the way I don't
know the answer but either way he ended
up serving the interests of Donald Trump
and of the Republicans who quite frankly
never cared whether Brett Kavanaugh
sexually assaulted anybody yeah I'm not
quite sure about that I think Jeff Flake
was just trying to play both sides
especially because he's on the way out
so he wants to look like he's above the
fray so so he satisfied Democrats by
asking for the investigation but
ultimately he also satisfied Republicans
by voting for the guy and you know in a
sense Republicans played it brilliantly
I don't know if they planned every stage
of it or or if it just kind of fell into
their laps in this way but it allowed
Republicans to say look we did an
investigation Democrats still aren't
happy but we did it and it's time to
vote on the confirmation the saving
grace Pat is that at least it's only oh
it's an appointment for life Oh unless
you get 2/3 of the Senate and a majority
of the house to say remove Cavanaugh
he's in for life or for as long as he
wants 51 votes required to confirm him
for life but you need 67 votes if you
want to remove
even in light of grossly inappropriate
circumstances that come to light it's a
total whitewash cover-up which we knew
now we just know for sure before we
started by suspecting it was a whitewash
cover-up then we had almost total
certainty that it was a whitewash
cover-up now we just know for sure which
I guess is nice yeah and could Democrats
have played it any better I'm not
totally sure because they don't have the
majority agree right at least they got
that one week investigation but it could
have been faulty what named Nathan J
Robinson said yesterday which is just
focus on the perjury from day one focus
on the perjury as opposed to an
investigation that we all kind of knew
wasn't really going to go anywhere
absolutely disgusting not every online
streaming service is the same and
today's sponsor title is not only
different from others in that they care
about the relationships between artists
and fans and they value diversity in
music they offer unlimited music and
video completely ad free you can find
music that you haven't heard you can
hear the classics that you've liked for
a long time but above all else they're
doing a benefit concert on October 23rd
it's their 4th annual benefit concert
called Title X Brooklyn and it's about
criminal justice reform it's about
reforming a system where more than
two-thirds of prisoners serving life
without parole
for nonviolent offenses are African
American it's about reforming a system
where 1 in 15 African American men is
incarcerated compared to one in 106
white men there are really important
organizations working on this issue the
equal justice initiative reform the
Innocence Project cut 50 and the net
proceeds from Title X Brooklyn all go to
supporting those nonprofits the concerts
in the past have featured artists like
Stevie Wonder Nicki Minaj jay-z Jennifer
Lopez do not miss the free live stream
of Title X Brooklyn on October 23rd tune
in donate to the cause at tidal dot-com
/ Brooklyn that is T I D al.com
for words
Brooklyn